They say breakfast is
the most important meal of the day
most important meal of the day
So we better eat breakfast.
A study from none other than Harvard University
states that men who regularly skip breakfast
have a 27% higher risk
of suffering a heart attack.
This disease will lead to heart attacks and strokes.
Heart attacks and strokes?
Oh no!
I skipped breakfast,
But I’m not worried because I now know
there’s no proof that
skipping breakfast causes heart attacks
or any other problem.
That Harvard study?
The authors actually concluded
it “remains unknown whether specific eating habits
influence heart disease risk”
There’s no proof that skipping breakfast
is harmful in any way.
It's been pushed, it doesn't really hold water
Nutritionist Ruth Kava points out that all
the claims about breakfast being especially important
are just unproven.
That strokes and heart attack news persists because
people who skip breakfast have more health problems
but that’s partly because
breakfast skippers are more likely
to smoke and eat unhealthy foods.
There is just no proof that
skipping breakfast itself causes problems.
I've skipped breakfast for years
That's fine.
Really? Fine?
It works for you. You're not fat.
[Stossel] We're all different.
Yeah. We're all different,
we have to do what's comfortable for us.
Another myth about breakfast is
that skipping it may make you fat.
People who skip breakfast were more likely
to be the big weight gainers over time.
The government claimed that, just 9 years ago.
Saying not eating breakfast has been associated with
excess body weight.
But that’s not true either, according to a new analysis
They looked on a number of different studies,
and they did not find that eating breakfast
helped people lose weight.
get it so wrong?
Partly because eating habits are hard to study.
You can’t follow test subjects for years
controlling what they eat.
Most studies are based on what people say they ate.
And people forget or lie.
[music] Kelloggs corn flakes
Also, we may have been suckered by studies
funded by cereal makers.
[Music] it’s great!
Of the 15 studies involving children
mentioned by the government,
five list funding from
General Mills or Kellogg.
Yeah, well they're the ones that are interested
in having their products sold,
Music
In fairness, not all cereal companies spin the results.
One study, funded by Quaker Oats,
found eating breakfast did not help people lose weight.
This study was unfavorable to Quaker Oats,
but Quaker Oats said “let's publish it.”
Good for Quaker Oats.
But let's not count on companies to
tell us the truth about nutrition
Study found people who didn't eat breakfast
could lose weight by starting to eat breakfast.
Kellogg's touted this on their cereal boxes.
Don't get your nutrition education from cereal boxes.
Are you okay?
But what if instead of a cereal box,
it was America’s first Lady on Sesame Street?
I am very tired and have no energy.
Well I think I know what would help.
What, secret service?
Air force one?
[laughs] No, Grover.
A healthy breakfast!
Now there is data that shows
Children who do not have decent nutrition
during the course of the day,
had been shown to do better
if they get some food into them in the morning.
That's where that comes from.
And it's valid?
it's appropriate.
Unfortunately, on Sesame Street,
Michele Obama doesn’t just say children.
She says everyone.
Grover, breakfast isn’t just for first ladies.
Everybody should have a healthy breakfast.
Oh not me.
And much of the media push nonsense like claims
that if you eat the right breakfast
you are going to end up boosting your metabolism,
losing the belly fat, restoring gut health
restoring gut health?
There is so much bad information out there.
The current consensus is
Eat breakfast if you're hungry.
Eat breakfast if you're hungry, if not, eat a little later.